thanks to endo Chino for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me look fly
to this day it's still hard to imagine
what two billion dollars actually looks
like but I think that jury wanted to
send a message
[Music]
hey legal eagles welcome back to the
channel and we have a special guest with
us here today
one of the greatest trial attorneys in
America today and an old friend our
Brent Wisner with the law firm BOM
headland who has I think received every
accolade you can receive as a trial
attorney these days and I think I think
most people recognize you as the
attorney who one two billion dollars
from Monsanto just a few weeks ago so
Brent welcome to the channel it's great
to have you here Thank You Devin it's
good to be here it's always good to see
an old friend so I think what people
would really like to hear is what is it
like to win two billion dollars from
Monsanto it's pretty unreal I mean I
remember sitting in the courtroom when
the jury was reading the verdict and it
was it was two different plaintiffs
right both Al and Alberta and when Al's
verdict came he got a billion dollars in
punitive damages and I realized oh my
god they're gonna give us two I remember
I turned around he looked at my
associate Pedram and I went and it was
pretty unreal to this day it's still
hard to imagine what two billion dollars
actually looks like but I think that
jury wanted to send a message and I gave
them an opportunity to do that it was
pretty cool all right so let's take a
step back for a second if people aren't
familiar with the Monsanto litigation
the iliad case is the third of three
cases and you've tried two of them let's
start with the first one
where you only won two hundred and
eighty nine million dollars that was the
Johnson case can you give us some
background about what that case was
about what the basics of the case were
and what your theme going into that
trial was sure so I mean this cases are
about a chemical called glyphosate which
is a active ingredient found in the
Roundup herbicide or pesticide there's
to give you a sense of how much has been
sprayed in our society the amount of
glyphosate that's been sprayed in the
United States by itself is more than
every other pesticide ever combined it
is in everything we eat it is everywhere
we go and mr. Johnson and the pillions
they sprayed roundup for a considerable
period of time and after spraying it for
a period of time they got something
called non-hodgkins lymphoma different
severa teas of cancer but it is a pretty
severe cancer and so we brought a
lawsuit against Monsanto one of the most
hated organizations or companies in the
world and we see allegedly allegedly yes
but I I mean it's really funny I've
gotten more free drinks at bars telling
people that I sue Monsanto than anywhere
else in my life I always firstly I say
to somebody when I meet them I'm gonna
plaintiff's attorney and I see him on
Santa and they go let me buy you a drink
so anyway run a lawsuit and I think the
theme the main principle behind both
cases in fact it was the first words out
of my mouth in both opening statements
was that this is a case about choice
it's about the right of every single
person in the courtroom to make a choice
about what chemicals they expose
themselves or their family to and
knowing whether that causes cancer is
part of that choice and that Monsanto
has robbed that choice of every single
person in this courtroom the pilly ads
mr. Johnson and in doing so they caused
cancer they've actually taken lives and
so you have to do something to fix it
that was a big part of the case that and
also trying to make the case seemed like
a truly historical moment I mean that's
a really important way to frame a case
because if the juries don't want to be
there but if you give them the idea that
they're making history I mean you can
really take them as far as you need to
go I mean there's so much I want to talk
about here myself and a trial lawyer
I mean I'm chomping at the bit to talk
about every single aspect of trial
tactics here let me start with this how
did you decide on that particular theme
and it is that a theme that carried
through both through the Johnson
litigation and through the
Eliott litigation itself I spent a lot
of time thinking about it and I kept
coming back to what is the moment right
what is the moment where the actual tort
occurs right and it's not actually when
you're spraying because when you're
spraying it you've already made the
decision to purchase the product and I
realized that all these cases come down
to a moment when you're sitting there in
a store or Home Depot or whatever and
you're looking at this wall roundup and
you're thinking should I buy this stuff
to get rid of the weeds in my house
that's that moment and that moments
captured by a question of choice right
and I feel like putting the jury in
putting basically everyone in those
shoes gets you to a place where they go
okay I can see how this lack of
disclosure of the cancer risk could
actually cause a real problem so that's
how we got there and kept going
different different ways different
themes and I kept coming back to that
moment yeah that moment was about choice
so to take one step back I mean this is
history-making litigation and you have a
long history of being a trial lawyer but
my understanding is that you did not
start with this case as release the the
Johnson litigation you were not
originally the lead trial lawyer for
that case yeah how how did that come to
your desk and how did you become the guy
that was going to be the lead trial
lawyer who was going to actually try the
thing in front of a jury in San
Francisco well I mean Devin you and I
know that you know you always want to be
the lead trial lawyer you always want to
be in the thick of things you always
wanted the opening you always want to
the closing because that's what I live
and breathe for back back in college and
we were doing this in our mock trial
days at UCLA and we're definitely going
to talk about okay of course of course I
mean you didn't teach me most of the
things I know about about being almost I
never will get you ever but um so two
weeks before the Johnson trial and I had
been working on the Monsanto roundup
litigation sort of generally for about a
year and a half so I knew this science
I knew the experts I knew how to prove
the case at least on paper
Mike Miller who was the lead trial
counsel he's seven years old and he was
out kites
on Virginia Beach Wow power to the guy
seven years old he's still kite surfing
hope I am doing that when I'm 70 and he
his safety harness didn't work right
and he ultimately went 30 miles per hour
into appear it was in the hospital he
almost died it was pretty horrible well
number two in his firm timlinson burg
literally leaves the hospital and calls
me and says hey Brent we got this case
going to trial in two weeks can you help
out like we can't do this by ourselves I
said absolutely man whatever you need I
can do it well the next Monday he then
had a grand mal seizure and he was
hospitalized for seven days and
basically I was the last man standing
which is one of the reasons why I you
know 35 years old was put in this really
important position of trying a massive
historical first case against Monsanto
involving Roundup
Mike Miller calls me from his hospital
bed and says Brian go get him and you
know I did and ironically in the last
trial in the piglia trial it my rebuttal
after the closing at the last thing I
said to the jury is I actually looked at
them and I said go get him so I kind of
came full circle so we see joke in
college and in law school that the ideal
job for a trial lawyer is not to have to
work all the discovery and all the
motions and the paperwork but to just
get called in at the last second and get
to go to trial somehow you got to a
position where you're living the dream
and I mean that on the one hand it
sounds amazing
that that's exactly what we always
wanted to do but getting a multi-million
potentially multi-billion dollar case a
week before trial that also sounds like
the most terrifying thing I've ever
heard in my entire life how in the world
do you go about preparing for that kind
of a trial when the whole world is gonna
be watching you there's a lot of
hyperventilating there's a lot of not
showing how scared and nervous you are
but I also think part of being a trial
lawyer is is sort of relishing that
pressure yeah relishing the anxiety of
the moment and I actually remember
thinking and as I that morning just
before the opening statement it was it
was like this is
this is this is what I've been waiting
for my whole life this moment for this
trial to be brought in you know complete
underdog taking on these massive
corporate lawyers who have who are the
most seasoned in the country and taking
them on and beating the crap out of them
and that's literally the dream but you
know one of the things that people don't
realize when it comes to trying case and
obviously you know this Devin but you
know the trial is is this small part
right hundreds and sometimes thousands
of hours of work that leads you to that
moment particularly in these complex
mass tort cases and so it's you know you
gotta relish the moment when you're
there yeah I mean it's a curse and a
blessing that if you are working on a
case for sometimes years you know the
case like the back of your hand it's
your baby you know it as well as your
own physical child and so when you get
to trial you don't have to work it up in
the same way as if you were just coming
in fresh but without having that benefit
of you know doing the discovery I mean
how long was the discovery you know the
the part of the iceberg that we don't
see the you know trial is the part that
we do see how long was that litigation
going on before it even got to trial
well to give you some some context this
is a good way of thinking about it so
there was I think 36 deposition so that
happened prior to trial that's a good
number of depositions each depositions
seven hours long yeah minimum and each
of those depositions probably takes a
hundred to 200 hours of prep so you
start doing the numbers there and it
becomes sort of astronomical in addition
to that there was over 10 million
documents produced by Monsanto we had
scientists were around the world we had
a lot of third party discovery against
other scientists I mean it was a
complicated case and you know one of the
things that we did in this case at least
in the Johnson case and we didn't pilly
it as well but in the first case one of
the things that I did that everyone
thought I was crazy for was I wanted the
smartest jury I could find
I wanted PhDs I wanted lawyers I wanted
people who could understand complex
scientific issues on my jury because I
knew that if they were just well lazy
not smart people or whatever they
wouldn't spend the time to understand
this
because when you look at the science we
win but if you just believe the EPA or
whatever you lose and so you need to
have people who are willing to look at
it truly in a new unit of time and give
you an actual assessment so that was
pretty pretty dangerous trial strategy
but it worked out yeah so you know on
the channel we talk about the voir dire
process because that is actually one of
the things that does show up in the
movies and TV shows sometimes is that
you will see the dramatic selection of
the jury so let's dive into that sure
what is your philosophy when it comes to
jury fraud ear which is the selection of
the jury is the part that non lawyers
actually do have some familiarity with
because they get called for jury duty
and you might be impaneled on on the
jury and you might have to get
questioned by an attorney but how do you
go about doing that process and and you
know obviously your your philosophy with
this particular case was get the
smartest one that you could what does
that process look like from from your
perspective well it's an interesting
process because most people who are in
that jury venire right which is the
group of people you're picking a jury
from most people don't want to be there
yeah most people want to avoid jury duty
and so the first sort of metric is you
want to find the people who want to be
there right because people who want to
be there will be more engaged they'll be
more interested the people who don't
want to be there will be half asleep
most of the trial right the other thing
that you want to do is you want to get
them talking lawyers love to hear
themselves speak it is just it is what
we love to do excuse me let me let me
vehement lis agree with your step I'd
like to continue to pontificate and
agree with that statement about the
vociferous Ness of attorneys I mean the
loquacious nosov lawyers is tonight
astounding and how much we like to talk
about things that we even agree on at
times yeah 100% agree so one thing is to
get them talking right because you need
a jury to talk you need to you need to
say things and speak their mind but I
think one of the other things this is a
strategy that we use particularly
examiner's just go I mean you're in San
Francisco this is not a jury pool that
likes Monsanto this is not a jury pool
that that that likes GMOs right these
are people who eat organic and want to
live a healthier lifestyle
so there's a natural dislike of Monsanto
walking in so one of the things that we
did from the very beginning is to
downplay our case I mean the first thing
we say to the jury is nothing can be
proven right cancer can't be proven
that's impossible
who here agrees who here agrees because
we want people to say yeah you can't
prove cancer we wanted to sort of
dislike the case because when they
actually get into the jury trial we're
gonna win them but we want to weed out
the bad people and so so much of our job
it's finding the badgers and then you
know trying to get them to be willing to
be on the jury cuz it's so easy to get
out of jury duty you just say oh I hate
Monsanto I can't be impartial and then
you're off so you got to get those
people to not say that or say oh I don't
like Monsanto but I can put that aside
and be impartial and so that's that was
the fight I mean when it comes to jury
selection that is the fight yeah
so let's dig down into some of the the
minutiae when I was trying a case I
wanted to be as relatable as possible to
the jury and you're not allowed to talk
to the jury outside of the you know
selection process and the actual trial
itself but I I remember I was walking
through a metal detector and I saw some
of the members of the potential jury and
you know I made a big show of taking
them the metal pieces out of my pocket
like ah gosh you know I'm stuck here
just like you are you know is there
anything that you do to you know use
every piece of the court process
available to you so that you can
ingratiate yourself with the jury and
the judge and you know sometimes even
the bailiff and people like that so I
mean the first thing you do is you
introduce everybody mmm right not just
the lawyers the paralegal the the person
who's operating the TEC at the Milosh
trial I actually introduced my parents
who were in the gallery in turties you
know Bobby Kennedy who had been a mentor
of mine I I wasn't was like a it was
like a name parade of all these people
who are part of the party were part of
our team it shows that you care about
everybody on your team I think people
relate to that immediately the other
thing that you have to do is not be
above anything right so so many lawyers
are like well I'm not going to move
chairs or I'm not gonna deal with
binders or whatever I have people for
that I never let anybody do anything but
me
I'm the one moving chairs I'm the one
handing the mic around givin it to
different jurors they see that I'm
person who has has no sense of pride or
ego that I'm just there to do my job and
I think that builds an incredible amount
of credibility it actually at the
pillared case it was so bad that during
the WOD year there was a break the judge
actually got the defense counsel goes
judge mr. Wisner is being too helpful
he's hanging around microphone not
handing the jury can come to stop doing
that oh my god actually quite funny is
there anything you can do in the jury of
YT or process to show that that you are
just one of everybody else you know
apart from you know taking all the the
boxes and and getting an objection
drawing an objection that you're being
too helpful that's that's a fantastic
objection to get so I think I think it's
really important to relate I mean first
of all put yourself in the shoes of the
deserves right they don't want to be
there they want any jobs to worry how
long the trial is gonna be the worried
about oh my god I'm a gonna get paid for
six weeks or anything there's so many
things that they're worried about and so
you know one things is you know everyone
starts introducing themselves ready to
begin hi my name is body bought him on
this body block I always go up there and
go hey hey everyone and I get them to
say hey back and I go I'm so sorry I
know none of you want to be here frankly
it sucks but I'm gonna do everything I
can to get you out of here but I picked
you because I really like you and they
all start laughing you know and you
immediately start creating a rapport
with them in a sort of genuine way right
not in like a false pretense way so for
example the defense lawyer he actually
saw me doing that he was like oh I gotta
do something charming too because there
he goes hey everyone I'm from Nevada Las
Vegas and but don't hold it against me
that the Raiders left right that was
like yeah this is not the right time to
make that you didn't understand where he
was right no one I mean that's assuming
a lot of things right if he had been a
Warrior's reference that would have been
a really good thing but he didn't get it
you know I mean it's so sort of relating
to them in a real way and I think a lack
of sincerity is obvious when someone's
being untruthful you know it but when
someone's being real you
really go this guy's a real person I
like them and that's a really important
part I mean you don't win the case by
the jury liking you jury can hate you
and you should still win or lose but if
they like you it takes away a weapon of
the defendant because when they attack
you in closing argument or they attack
you in front of the jury that the jury
did gets defensive they go what are you
doing I like that guy what are you doing
you can't attack him that actually has
happened in all the trials monstera
always comes after me personally and it
always backfires every single time yeah
I mean that's so huge because a lot of
lawyers and I probably put myself in
this camp say that the trial itself is
won and lost on on credibility you have
one opportunity to put your your case
out there and if the jury doesn't like
you or the judge doesn't like you it's
gonna be a huge uphill battle and maybe
credibility won't win the case for you
but if you lose your credibility I think
you're you're just done it's there's no
way to recover from that are the things
that happened in the Johnson Iliad case
that you think bolstered your
credibility and the credibility of your
witnesses that you know helped build
that in front of the judge the jury yeah
I think there's a split within the the
trial lawyer community there's the group
that says never show weakness always be
right always be the alpha dog the
courtroom I don't agree with that like
at all I think that's the terrible
approach particularly particularly in a
more dynamic and diverse environment
like San Francisco I think being real is
way more important and so for example on
the pillared case during my opening
statement I actually said a fact that
was wrong I say that they had sprained
it they sprayed over 1,500 gallons of
Roundup it's actually they have sprayed
it for 1,500 days but not 1500 gallons
and I said that wrong and I realized
that I'd said that wrong and so the
first witness I had that had to deal
with this issue I go hey dr. Sawyer
listen during opening statement I told
this jury that they had sprayed 1500
gallons is that true no it's not what
did I get wrong
well it's 1500 days thank you doctor
sorry I apologize ladies and gentlemen I
should have done that I just say I own
it and you do that and it shows a level
of a willingness to be wrong in front of
I think it goes a long way because they
know I'm not trying to fool them but I
care more about the truth than I do
necessarily about you know being right
and if you do that then it leads them to
the world of okay here's the evidence I
believe that evidence here's their
evidence I see that evidence can go on
the guy that belief yeah that's how you
win Oh God I mean that's just a great
point because no case is ever going to
be perfect so you're going to have bad
facts or you're gonna have bad law and
you're going to have to craft your case
around those potential weaknesses and I
love that story because you're turning a
weakness into a strength you you made a
misstatement in your opening statement
and if it just stayed there you know the
other side is going to have the
transcript they're gonna have the
recordings and at closing argument
they're gonna bring that out and just
say you can't trust mr. Wisner because
he made this statement exactly and
instead you use that as part of your
case in chief you come out you
acknowledge the mistake and in the grand
scheme of things it doesn't matter it's
not like the jury is going to you know
rely on this one fact forever but now
you have shown that you are a
trustworthy person exactly and even if
it makes you look stupid in the short
term that you did something wrong or you
had a misstatement or you you made a
flub the the jury knowing that they can
trust you is probably more important at
the end of the day and you know where
you see that the most is actually in
direct examination right so direct
examinations are a show right you have
your witness you know what they're gonna
say you've practiced the questions you
know what their opinions are there's no
surprise here but what I'll do is I'll
actually ask some some pretty harsh
questions to my own witness I'll go hold
on doctor wait a second who are you to
say the EPA is wrong I mean what gives
you the right to say that this
organization is wrong obviously
I've cleared this question with them
before I'm not just dropping this in
their lap but I play a sort of devil's
advocate in my direct and it creates so
much credibility because there's
somebody in that juror who I that
a question it was like wait a second who
is this person right yeah and you always
have a great answer so for example dr.
poore da he was saying how the EPA
didn't apply their own guidelines to
glyphosate and that's why that hit came
to a different conclusion how am I go
hold on dr. Portillo who are you who are
you to tell this jury that they're not
following the EPA guidelines this is
your own waste viola witness I'm like
I'm like come on I'm like look at drug
who's this guy think he is he goes well
mr. Wisner I wrote the guidelines okay
and then I move on but that's a more
powerful way of getting to that question
and answer than saying so you wrote the
guidelines does that mean that you can
criticize I mean I mean right being a
sort of confrontational direct examiner
can go a long way to sort of convincing
a jury that you really do have the goods
I think that's a that's a great segue
into some of the inaccuracies of what
people see on TV and in movies obviously
nobody's gonna want to watch a movie
that deals with literally years of just
reading documents and writing briefs so
it's no surprise that Hollywood will try
and condense these things into a more
palatable drama although you can come to
legal eagle to watch me talk about the
accuracy or lack thereof and all these
TV shows and movies but given that the
trial itself can last days or weeks and
sometimes months for example how long
was Johnson how long was period the job
de guiche was six weeks and the pillared
case was nine weeks okay Wow
I mean imagine being on the jury for
nine weeks having to be away from your
family and your job obviously a lot of
its just going to be shuffling papers
entering things into evidence how do you
keep the jury's attention and make sure
that they pay attention and get the
really important facts even when you're
dealing with sometimes really really
elaborate and obscure you know
scientific issues you know it's really
interesting I'd love to see how cases
were tried before the film industry you
guys know it because it's really a it's
really a chicken and egg situation
because because everyone has seen so
many movies where they sees all this
drama they've seen law and order I mean
it's actually why I became a lawyer like
Law & Order but that's something that
would be fun my job in many ways
to create sort of cinematic drama in the
courtroom when it wouldn't naturally be
there and so there's different ways of
doing that I mean I try like so when I'm
cross-examining I make it a point to
storm around the courtroom throw
documents slam them on the thing
point cajole and I do that not
necessarily because it's more convincing
because the jury goes from like ooh
what's gonna happen next you know I mean
they get into I'm watching a movie now
this is what I think Isles were about
right so this isn't funny it's funny
Hollywood has actually created an onus
on us to make it Hollywood but it
wouldn't naturally be that way and it's
it comes in different ways and I think
that's we come to cross-examination
because there's tension there yeah it
comes in openings it comes in closings
there was a really powerful thing to do
when you're on Direct and it's something
that very few litter knees are willing
to do again it goes to credibility but
it's where I ask the witness a question
the answer is bad for me and I'll be
like so sir based on all this it clearly
causes cancer he's like no I wouldn't
say that and the jury looks me like oh
my god like this is this is all gone
sideways damn and it makes it
entertaining so you have to create those
dramas as much as you can and I'll be
honest I did some of that in the pillion
case I think in a way that you know
probably angered the judge I tell ya I
do tell soso you crossed a line and made
way too much drama a little far so we
had it's a roundup case right so it's
pesticide and we actually had a
container of the roundup that mr. and
mrs. Polly had actually used on their
properties and we had cleaned it out it
was it was totally cleaned out and I had
an expert on there and I picked it up
and he's like you should be wearing
gloves and my osore put on gloves you
know and I'm holding it and and that
wasn't playing that actually was a
natural sort of thing that occurred and
as I'm as I'm kind of demonstrating how
it gets used and it shows you how it
gets on your leg and all that stuff I
realized that there was a hydraulic pump
on it and I was like oh look at that
it's still working and so I pulled the
hydraulic pump and I said you like this
and they only can you spray it and this
mist came out and it was right next to
the different and two of the jurors were
like I wonder I was like wiping his face
I'll freaked out
and I was like oh boy and the dead like
mister was about to put that away right
now I was like yes yeah I put it away
and then one of the jurors were in a
question because they could write
questions in in California state court
and I said you know what was in the
container and so we had this long debate
with counsel and the judge and the judge
ultimately gave a curative instruction
which is you know disregard or whatever
in the original curative instruction
that Monsanto wanted was to disregard
everything I said about the bottle I was
like well your honor that's not really
fair that there was a lot of Robin
testimony she really just be about what
was in the bottle she's like okay fine
so the jury comes back in and she goes
ladies and gentlemen I just want you to
know that there was only water in that
bottle so it's perfectly safe
I probably pushed that a little too far
when I have a jurors worried about being
you know sprayed with chemicals I
probably taking the drama too far but
they paid attention I mean that's an
advanced trial tactic I love that sort
of inside baseball that actual trial
tactics have been changed because of the
public perception and again as any good
trial lawyer would do you're turning a
potential disadvantage that people are
bored from watching a multi-day multi
week trial and you're turning that on
its head by creating drama to punctuate
the points that you're trying to make in
these particular cases do you think that
other attorneys are using the same
opportunities that you are or do you
think that you're outside the norm in
being able to create that drama and use
that emotional punch when you need to I
think that there's some plaintiffs
lawyers trial lawyers who are doing this
on a regular basis very effectively in
fact I've learned a lot of my techniques
other than of course from you from when
we were in college and doing a mock
trial at UCLA but you know mark Lanier
he's probably considered the most
preeminent trial lawyer in the world
plaintiffs side and I've learned a lot
of these techniques from them about how
to create interest where other ones
lacking a really good example is
depositions so we take these seven our
depositions right
you cannot play a seven hour deposition
to a jury they will kill you Oh
they are so boring and there's so many
legal technical questions that get asked
the deposition being questions taken
under oath outside of the trial itself
it's part of the discovery process where
you're in a conference room you're just
asking questions there's a stenographer
writing down the answers and sometimes
things go wrong and you might have to
call the judge but for the most part the
judge is not there it's just you the
witness and opposing counsel so you know
these now they're limited to seven hours
before you could go much longer
yeah the Federal Rules have allowed you
to go longer now so yeah these are these
can be very very boring things
hey legal eagles it's Devin from the
future I just wanted to pop in real
quick and let you know that today's
interview was brought to you by indogene
Oh my favorite suit maker I'm wearing an
Indo Chino suit right now I was wearing
an Indo Chino suit in the past when I
was conducting this interview it
actually worked out really well I
brought a sport coat with me and Brent
happened to bring one too or like why
don't we have an interview with each
other you just won two billion dollars
against Monsanto that'll be interesting
and yeah I love my Indo Chino suits and
I actually asked Indo Chino specifically
to give legal eagles the best possible
deal and they were happy to oblige they
gave legal eagles the exclusive ability
to buy any premium suit for three
hundred and fifty nine dollars that is
the best deal you will find anywhere all
you have to do is enter the promo code
legal eagle at checkout if you have any
inclination to get a new suit you owe it
to yourself to try custom that's the
promo code legal eagle at checkout to
get any premium suit for three hundred
and fifty nine dollars for a fully
custom suit and believe me once you get
a custom suit tailored for you you will
never ever go back and I really
appreciate you guys using the promo code
or using the link in the description it
really helps out this channel but enough
of all of that back to the interview
with a guy that's gonna take down
Monsanto and so you know one of the
things is and obviously you want to play
certain portions of it so like in
California because of the subpoena
limitation powers I can't force a
Monsanto witness in Montana and st.
Louis to come testify at my trial I
can't so I only can play videos from
deposition so one of the things that we
do to make them more interesting is we
use three cameras we use one on the
questioner one on the witness we have a
camera on a document camera or
bored we even have a camera on like
documents in another way we can actually
afford cameras and what we do is we film
all of them at the same time and we
played with a jury it's like a
television show it goes to the question
it goes to the answer it goes to the
question it goes to the answer because
they've done studies right people are
used to watching clips for 12 seconds at
a time
right right a screen changes every 12
seconds and if you don't have that it's
gets boring and they fall asleep and so
we've had a lot of really really really
good reactions to causing that back and
forth in our depositions and they kind
of become like kind of more dramatic and
they kind of more fun and it goes to the
the document camera it goes to the
person and you know one of them I
actually did where I was standing and
the camera was following me as I was
asking questions like full-on you were
standing in a deposition yeah they were
filming me as I walk around so it could
look more authentic yeah become more
interesting for the jury yeah Wow three
cameras I mean can you imagine someone
being so vain as to use three shaaka
yeah but I've actually never heard that
that's a great tactic to know that you
know some depositions are gonna be
important enough that you're going to
show it to the jury in trial so you use
a multicam setup to be able to cut while
they're saying the same thing mmm it's
not breaking up the actual testimony but
you're using it to keep the attention of
the jury I mean you're thinking so many
steps ahead yeah I mean whenever you're
litigating and obviously different
lawyers have different approaches but at
least within my firm and least
personally everything is towards the
trial yeah every question I ask is how
is this gonna be used at trial
everything has to be and if you do that
you do it right well then you get to go
to trial and get to billion dollar
verdicts right I mean that that's how
you do it and you know so many lawyers
are so busy or so used to settling or so
used to not actually being a trial
lawyer that's the big difference so you
see today good trial lawyers have
everything about trial and how we gonna
present it I mean we do things and I'm
pretty maniacal for example like my
table I cancelled a bone from the jury
is meticulously organized I have
everything in the same spot because
studies have shown that if you look more
organized juries believe you more right
even you said nothing
prynt except that you have an organized
desk that's it and it's amazing how
little things like that can really cute
a jury into being like okay this guy's
for real I trust them yeah it's hard
because I'm so young right I don't have
great that much gray hair I don't have
the sort of season old personal thing
right so I got to show that I know
everything yeah everyone that ever has
believe that lawyer knows more than
everybody and everyone believes and
that's kind of my goal I mean that's so
funny because do you remember in mock
trial when we had the idea that we would
get rid of all the paperwork on the desk
at all and only have this like tiny
eight by five little sheet to scribble
notes on and that would be the only
thing we had at counsel table I don't
think that worked very well he must have
improved on that we have systems but
I'll tell you what haven't changed is I
don't use a script you know every judge
always comments mr. Wisner you don't
have any notes when you're
cross-examining and I go absolutely not
and that's something I learned that you
say a mock trial and it blows the jury
away I mean blows them away cuz they're
like this guy does it all in his head
this guy knows that it's like what they
see on TV
exactly now here's one trick a
technological trick so and I'll do my
closing I always use a PowerPoint right
but what I do is I actually take a
screen I put it at the base of the where
the the bar is between the jury and the
lawyers and I have the next slide that's
gonna be up so I know what the next
slides gonna be as I'm doing it they
don't know that I know it today
so as I'm going through and I'm like and
you know what that is exactly what he
said boom and all of a sudden it comes
up they're like how does this guy know
he knows everything it's just like he
sees into the future in it it's just
goes right there in front of my feet
that's awesome what do you think are the
most pivotal parts of the trial itself
because a lot of it is monotonous a lot
of it is perfunctory and and some of it
is is duplicative what do you think are
the parts of the trial itself where the
trial is won or lost in front of the
jury I mean I think there's there's
really a couple clear moments where to
make a break in the case the first is
what err jury selection yeah no question
I mean you picked the wrong jury you're
gonna lose you picked the right jury you
can win and you can lose a case of water
very easily
I remember one my first case I ever
tried actually out Alexandria Virginia
you actually came to your closing you
came to my closing and I did the opening
statement at Mike Miller the same guy
who actually tried the pillion case with
me and the same guy who you know was
injured for the Johnson case he actually
came to my opening statement in that
trial he went and he saw the opening
statement comes back to the war room he
goes Brent I just want to know that was
probably one of the best opening
statements I've ever seen in my life and
you're gonna lose
I said what are you making he goes look
at your jury and I looked at my jury and
there's nothing I can say to win that
jury I mean it was never gonna happen I
was it was not gonna it was never never
I was never gonna win that trial so you
can make or break the case of one year
the next moment is opening statement
because that's the first time you're
talking substantively about the case and
the jury is listening and some people
have different theories about it some
people say well beauty has to be short
punchy get in and out I don't agree with
that at all if you're gonna make a jury
give you billions of dollars you have to
show them that you earned it and you got
to show them everything my opening
statements were running between three
and a half to four hours which are very
long and then the next moment is your
first witness right because I listened
to what what do you have to say let's
hear what you're putting this I have to
say so you always bring your rock stars
their first witness no question and that
one should be the most polished the most
clean
there should be no real evidentiary
issues that's the one where you just
hammer them and the last and probably
the most important part very often
people think it's closing argument but
it's actually not because by the time
you get to closing argument the jury's
heard openings they forget all the
testimony right I think they know what
they're gonna go where they're going
they know what they think it's their
first witness so so the defendants first
witness and there's no question that
that moment you have to obliterate them
you have to destroy that witness as hard
and as aggressively as you can because
if you can take out their first witness
they are done and actually in Johnson
their first witness I decimated and and
piglia the first witness I decimated it
so so in those two cases who did
Monsanto put up first was it the same
person and what were the the strategies
and tactics that you use to
you know to take down their first
witness well it's kind of weird because
every time I cross examine one of
Monsanto's witnesses we never see them
again I think they just quit they go I'm
not doing this anymore this is not worth
it
so in in the Johnson case their first
witness was this guy named al Khateeb he
was a weed scientist and it was
hilarious um we didn't like the things
that grow in you exactly he wasn't like
no I mean oh that would've been funny
but no he's actually how to kill weeds
okay people who smoke weed don't like
this guy because he kills weed in any
event he was up there and it was really
funny he was wearing a suit with a
purple tie and it's this whole getup and
I when I was cross-examining him I go
isn't it true that you told the world
that this international agencies
actually very respected and we have to
consider what they say when they say
something causes cancer she's like I've
never said that I go really well here's
a news article I pulled this up out of
Google where he literally was saying
that he's like I've never said that at
any meeting I go oh really
I handed in the artnet article he looks
at it and he goes oh you guys look I go
do you see that picture yeah that's you
right yeah see that tie right there yeah
that's the same tie you're wearing right
now yeah yeah no that was all right
experts buy more than one tie before he
testified and he was just like this is
my favorite I'm like Oh looks good on
you sir but you did say that didn't you
and he was like oh yeah and then at one
point I was a you of a financial
interest and whether or not people spray
wheat she's like no I don't and I go
don't you have a patent oh I do yeah I
handed him a US patent under oath with
his name I mean I decimated the guy and
then in the Johnson case their first
witness was dr. Bello and we had a
moment between when she first starts
testifying and when she before she
offers an opinion they do something they
laid your foundations you know are you
an expert can you testify about things
and then there's a short period of war
and it's funny because in mock trial we
always use that opportunity to to attack
the witness's credibility right but
during our trial
Monsanto didn't do that with us singing
one of our experts they'd go the judge
would you like to vada and they'd say no
your honor we rest on our papers okay
and then we'd proceed here the first
witness would you father and I go yes
your honor I would like to Vlad ear and
I walk into the fence counts when I go
you should sit down
take a while and I just took her apart
so the boy dear process when it comes to
an expert is to test their credentials
to make sure that they are capable of
testifying for some reason we use the
same French term that means to speak and
to say for both jury selection and for
experts I don't know why but so yeah I
mean that's that's pretty unusual
because when it comes to these
multi-million dollar pieces of
litigation there is your your Dalbert
motion and you've already tested a lot
of the gatekeeping functions of the
judge but you still have an opportunity
to kind of put your chips on the table
or try and take their chips away from
their expert opinions right so I that's
not surprising to me that most most
lawyers and probably most defense
lawyers are not going to be in the habit
of really taking advantage of wadiya but
again that's a great example of having
an opportunity and and taking it in a
way that I think most lawyers are not
going to do yeah and it also depends on
the expert I mean if they're truly the
most spectacularly qualified it almost
it's not worth your time like to give
you some context so the juxtaposition so
the first expert I go through a resume
and her see me I've talked a lot of
publications and basically at the end of
it and I kind of hammer her pretty hard
in a bit she goes yeah I guess really
determining what causes cancer isn't my
expertise that's what she testified at
that moment stop I look at the jury go
look at the judge I go Your Honor and
looking at the jury at this time I moved
to exclude this witness's testimony in
its entirety she just admitted she's not
even an expert and I'm not even looking
at the judge I'm looking at the jury the
jury is like smile and a laugh and kind
of giggling because they know I just
took her apart and it does he goes you
know denied mister was there and I
proceeded and so I sit down and so the
first time she testifies about an actual
opinion she did that movie is annexed by
the jury just think she's a joke so that
was the first witness yeah I mean the
damage is done regardless of what the
judge has you know excluded her
testimony exactly you've done the
rhetorical damage whether or not it is
admitted to evidence
nicely but then the next witness was
actually my witness again and he had a
PhD from UCLA and whatever and actually
his opinions really weren't that
important but you know I figured
whatever so the judge goes mr. wisdom
would you like to laud dear I gotta go
yes your honor and the jury is like Oh
what's he gonna do this time really
intense like is the last one I was so
brutal I got there I go dr. Phelan I
have a very important question from you
you know yeah and I go isn't UCLA the
greatest university in the world he goes
oh yeah and I go good I went there for
college no questions your honor
i sat down and the jury's laughing the
judge is laughing everyone's laughing I
mean it i underscore how bad the first
witness was and at the same time I
feared myself to the court that's
awesome and also it's good to get that
in as a matter of law that UCLA is the
the best university out there don't
think it can be disputed often these
experts are going to be really world
class experts in their field
they're going to be talking about some
kind of medical thing or mathematical
thing or some science-based thing that
we often don't have that kind of
background how do you go about preparing
for cross-examining some other signs
witness who has probably gone to school
and specialized in some part of science
that you know we have heard about for
purposes of this trial but we don't have
that kind of background how do you go
toe-to-toe with someone who is an expert
in their field you know during the
Johnson case they called this very
well-respected toxicologists Warren
Foster to the stand and he was from
Canada and he had this long gray
ponytail and you know just being he's
walking up walking up to the stand to
get ready for his cross-examination the
jury hasn't come in yet I walk up the
stand I go hey doctor can I ask you two
quick questions personal question he was
like yeah what's up I go the ponytail
are you a hippie or do you ride Harley's
he looks at me he goes I don't ride
motorcycles but you know me they happy
in it made me like the guy you know and
so my actual cross-examination of him
was the
pleasant mm-hmm Oh smiley I was laughing
I was giggling I was I wasn't me that
was very very sort of jovial and I got
him to say things that he never in a
million years would have said his big
argument was that these tumors in his
rodent studies were fell within the
historical range okay which is the
percentage of mice that would get that
tumor naturally the background rate and
so they've been dosed with roundup
probably life is a but yeah glyphosate
so the active ingredients in roundup
these mice have been doused with this
some of them statistically are gonna get
cancer or tumors just by virtue of
happenstance right and so if you have
elevated rates of tumors it has to be
above that background rate or else no
you don't know if it's just the
background rate and his whole argument
was that they fell within that
background rate so what that rate was
was the issue right he was saying it's
12 percent my experts were saying it's 2
percent and you know which one is it so
he goes up there and I go doctor
you would agree with me sir numbers
they're important right and he goes damn
straight they are especially when it's
the number on my paycheck and he he
didn't understand what he was doing like
he thought he was like being you know an
everyman person you know we're lady to
everybody cause everyone cares about the
number on their paycheck but it really
looked like he was saying yeah make sure
Monsanto pays me all the dollars they
have the baby he gave me this testimony
and then I go through it and it was
amazing it was a very Perry Mason moment
you know very dramatic he's talking
about the background right and he says
it's 12 percent it's 12 percent I guess
so you're saying the average is 12
percent yes yes all right well let's
look at it so I put up this study that
he said and I go through all the numbers
and it's 1% it's 2% it's 1% 1% 1% and
there's like 40 numbers and they're all
one or two there's one of them that has
12% and I go sir when he said it was the
average I go I'm not the best at math
but look at how in the world does that
average to 12 percent and he goes forgot
his glasses he reads it closer it's like
a long positive
huh yeah I guess I'm just wrong
I go doctor it's a big man to admit it
no further questions i sat down that was
the last question we asked the guy and
that was the last question they asked
and they couldn't even rebuild it and
they're like get him out yeah and that's
how we kick their butt yeah well that's
why you get tagged with a two billion
dollar verdict yeah
all right so inevitably when you get one
of these multi-million dollar or
multi-billion dollar verdicts you get
these people who say this is just a
greedy plaintiff or a greedy plaintiff's
attorney who's just looking for a payday
you know the science isn't there I've
used round up my whole life I've never
got contracted anything what do you say
to those people especially since
potentially they could be on your next
jury I mean I'd have to say that the
strongest piece of evidence in our case
is actually the science which is I kind
of talked about this earlier it's why we
want scientists on our jury if you can
get them because they understand it look
at the science of roundup and glyphosate
there's really three pillars okay
they're studies that look at actual
humans who were exposed in the real
world and says okay other people who are
spraying roundup do they get more cancer
that's the epidemiology then there's
this sort of middle pillar which is the
sort of cellular studies and that's like
okay when we apply roundup to a human
cell what happens to the cell and
specifically we're looking for does it
cause genetic damage because that's how
you cause a mutation that leads to
cancer and then the third pillar is the
animal studies you know they have these
laboratory experiments where they study
these animals for for their entire
lifetimes and it's highly controlled and
they see here are some that aren't
exposed to any glyphosate here are some
that are and are the ones that are being
exposed to glyphosate do they get more
tumors right and when you put all the
science together it's pretty
overwhelming for example in the animal
studies and every single mouse study
that's been done I think it's been six
or seven of them every single one
there's elevated rates of malignant
lymphoma and we're talking about
lymphoma we look at the cellular studies
it shows genetic damage in human
lymphocytes which is how you get
lymphoma and when you look at the human
data
it shows that people who are generally
exposed to ground-up have greater rates
of lymphoma across-the-board it's
pointing in a specific direction now one
of the things that's really important
and you spend a lot of time educating
the jury about this in blood here and in
your opening statement is the burden of
proof mm-hmm because if I had to prove
something with absolute certainty that
it causes cancer it would be almost
impossible I mean that is a high high
burden but we just have to do more
likely than not you know hunger and City
I mean exactly
we always thought you know you have a
featherweight scale right they put one
feather on one side and it's just
slightly moves and we win the way I like
to tell the jury is if you hear all the
evidence and you go well I think it
causes cancer but I'm not sure good we
win that's all we need to do I think it
might cause cancer that's it and when
you have that lower standard which is
very different in the criminal context
but in the civil context you know it's
not that hard to prove now if we had to
prove it with absolute certainty I think
that would be a much different question
and I think very often people go you're
just making up science or you're not
actually doing it or this is just
plaintiffs lawyers and inflaming the
jury's emotions they don't understand
the legal system and actually the juries
are properly applying and weighing the
evidence in this case yeah I mean that's
a big difference between the civil
system that is built to compensate
victims for their damages versus the
criminal system where you have to prove
the state has to prove a crime beyond
the reasonable doubt which is a very
very high standard and right you know
you can't ever numerically compare a
reasonable doubt to preponderance of the
evidence but if it's 51 percent versus
49 percent in terms of certainty then
the plaintiff should win if they
approved 51 percent and yeah
unfortunately I think a lot of people
don't understand the difference between
the burden of proof in in criminal law
versus civil law and that's why we spend
so much time educating the jury about
that exact issue from the very from day
one from what year or picking the jury
the other thing that's really
complicated is there's actually a third
burden and that's for punitive damages
right you have to show that they acted
with a deliberate
disregard to human safety you have to
show that they acted with malice and you
have to show that not by preponderance
of the evidence by by clear and
convincing evidence which is somewhere
in the sort of scale somewhere between
two exactly between the pond urns and
beyond reason abouts so we don't know
where that's somewhere in between it and
I think for that one you should lease a
just anyone here really believe that
Monsanto wasn't trying to make money
knowing that it causes cancer and you
know what yeah then we're done
right Jimmy getting to the malleus proof
is actually relatively easy and all
three juries that has been unanimous
yeah okay wow that's incredible and it's
also important to educate the jury
because the term malice in the punitive
damage standard is not what we would
normally think of in terms of mouths
it's not like someone at Monsanto was
like I hate these people are going to
make them suffer you know it's a term of
art that has been defined by you know
hundreds of pages of case law and jury
instructions and statutory law so you
have to educate the jury and sometimes
you have to educate the judge at every
step of the way because you know we're
tried by a jury of our peers who are
people that are not lawyers and and
they're not steeped in this every day
like like we are so yeah I mean the
education point is huge and I think you
know it's something that when people get
angry about these kind of verdicts
people say oh to billion dollars that's
outrageous you know this is what's wrong
with the jury system you know those
people don't understand just how
important the jury system is to the way
we practice law because believe it or
not juries very often get it right
I mean sometimes they make mistakes for
sure but they're more often right than
wrong and it's it's it's a method that's
fair and it's transparent and it gives
us confidence that things are being
adjudicated by our peers and people who
want to get away with just regard the
jury system they're either defense
lawyers sorry mister mr. stone I've
spent a lot of time as a plaintiff's
lawyer okay these were defense lawyers
or they've never been in a situation
where they felt they needed recourse to
the jury system because if you're
someone who's hurt if you're someone
who's been harmed or
really want to make a change because you
see like something's wrong in the world
taking your access to the jury system
away is is is a real problem yeah and I
think that very often with tort
reformers or the hot coffee people all
these people who think all these juries
are crazy when you really dig down deep
you find out that like for example the
hot coffee story it's not what you think
there's a great documentary about it
yeah and I think it's really important
for people to take a step back and not
listen to that nonsense and actually say
okay if I was hurt what would I want if
you were hurt you'd want to have a jury
- yeah so wait so you're suggesting that
Twitter law degree is not the same as
being a member of a jury and watching a
trial from start to finish for nine
weeks and learning everything from start
to finish I find that hard to believe
shocking yeah who ever thought it's
crazy yeah yeah just reading one article
or maybe a tweet storm about it is not
the same as actually being on that jury
and listening to the facts on both sides
for weeks at a time
yeah I'll tell you what you take all the
people who are the trolls and the people
who think they know better you put them
on one of my juries and the seven weeks
they'll be singing the same tune because
unless they're dishonest with themselves
the evidence in this case is
overwhelming and there's a reason why
the juries have been unanimous so
consistently I mean these are people
from different walks of life from all
over the state of California who keep
coming to the same conclusion when they
see the evidence because it causes
cancer and it's because Monsanto knew
what causes cancer and they just didn't
care so in the Johnson case you
originally won 289 million dollars on
behalf of the plaintiff that's right
that was later chopped down by the judge
in briefing but my understanding is that
the jury on their own time wanted to
dispute with the judge chopping their
own verdict down can you talk about what
happened there first of all is that true
did the jury come back as a for you it's
unbelievable and and we had no role in
trying to get the jury there okay so
after the verdict the judge has post
trial motions where she hears arguments
as to why maybe the verdict
be thrown out or the the verdict should
be reduced or whatever and she had
written a tentative ruling which is her
her initial thoughts of what she's
thinking about doing and in her
tentative she had actually got rid of
the punitive and said we have to have a
new trial and she had basically said I'm
very seriously considering getting rid
of the rest of the case basically
throwing out the whole verdict and
that's crazy because judges rarely
deviate from their tentative ruling if
they went to the trouble of actually
writing down what they think they want
to do the odds of you being able to
convince them to go against that and
here she was saying to get rid of all
the punitive damages which is most of
the 289 million right I mean the odds of
being able to talk a judge down from
that are I mean maybe one in ten yeah
probably less so we get there and and
there's ten of the jurors are there to
hear the argument they've read the
tentative and they're furious about what
the judge is doing this is this is how
long after trial this is what six weeks
eight almost six to seven weeks after
the trial so ten of the twelve jurors
came back a month and a half later after
their service was already done that's
right
they have no reason to be there they
could just go out living their merry
lives they've done their job but they
care so much about this case they care
so much about their verdict date he
spent so much of their life doing this
they want to see what happens and so
they all show up and we have this
argument and it's a it's a rough
argument you know Monsanto was accusing
me of all sorts of wrongdoing and it
goes back and forth and I was on a
Friday
that weekend those jurors go on it's
amazing they they go on Twitter they go
on they start talking to news reporters
they go on the local television they
write letters to the judge telling her
why she shouldn't do this why it's wrong
and you know the judge turned around her
tentative she kept the verdict and she
did reduce the period of damages down
you know it was a 289 million dollar
verdict should reduce the whole thing to
about 80 million so there was a big
reduction but she she gave something
called a remittitur which is sort of
interesting it's a complicated legal
issue basically the judge is reducing it
and if Montana
pays it the case is done but if Monsanto
appeals it then we have the right to
appeal the reduction so if we accept the
remittitur we cannot appeal it after
they pay it but if so it was a sort of a
trade off and Monsanto obviously wants
to roll the dice they want to play a 200
million-dollar game of chicken on the
game on the appeal and we feel pretty
confident that we're actually gonna get
the money back so we'll see how it goes
but this jury cared so much about this
case that they I've never seen a jury do
that it's just unheard of and actually
one of the jurors to this day has been
going to the later trials
I don't blog about that Wow and
commenting on it and he's now writing a
book about it and it's really cool how
we got them so engaged as jurors that
it's literally changed their lives that
jury service it's pretty cool that's
incredible it's a testament to your
skill as a trial attorney I could sit
here and and swap more stories with you
and listen to your trial stories
probably for the rest of the day maybe
we need to start a podcast or something
let me ask you a couple quick rapid-fire
questions
the first is what is your favorite
lawyer movie I have to say my favorite
legal movie would have to be a few good
men okay that cross-examination when Tom
Cruise is you know I want answers you
think you're God I want the truth
you got handled I love that so much
completely inaccurate but I'd love it so
much I would be remiss especially on
legal eagle if I didn't ask you what you
think the most inaccurate part of legal
movies is it would be the time between
when the case starts and when the trial
happens it's always like a month or two
months or like a week it's usually like
five or six years
it's just preposterous how fast things
it's like in Game of Thrones how fast I
can travel between west and places in
Westeros it says that possible Brent
it's been an absolute pleasure talking
to you today I could talk to you for
hours and I hope we'll get a chance to
do around two and I guess I'll interview
you again next time you win several
billion dollars from a multinational
company hey Devin it just occurred to me
that jacket looks amazing on you where
did you get it oh my gosh thanks
much I got it from Indo Chino who's a
sponsor of today's video don't you know
by now you guys know the drill I love my
Indo Chino suits and I negotiated a
special deal for legal eagles all my
suits are now custom made by indogene Oh
including the blazer that I'm wearing in
this video see the secret to a great
suit is all about fit I'm a reasonably
athletic guy and I can never buy suits
off the rack because they simply just
never fit right if the shoulders fit the
waist is too small if the waist is right
I'll bust out of the sleeves but within
the Chino you can send your measurements
in online or you can go to one of their
stores and have a stylist take your
measurements I made an appointment went
to the store in person and had a stylist
work with me for over 90 minutes when I
went in for the first time all of that
was completely free my personal stylist
took my measurements and a couple weeks
later I got the best fitting suit of my
entire life
it was perfect right out of the box endo
Chino will make you a fully custom suit
tailored specifically for you for less
than $400 and the best part is they
still use the best materials like super
140 wool and cashmere in fact I asked
Indo Chino to give legal eagles
specifically the best possible deal and
they're giving you guys the exclusive
ability to buy any premium suits for 359
that is the best deal you will find
anywhere I will never buy an
off-the-rack suit again legal eagles can
get any premium Indo Chino suit for just
359 when you enter the code League
illegal to check out or use the link in
the description clicking on the link
really helps out this channel that's
Indo Chino comm promo code legal eagle
for the best custom suit of your entire
life